Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es mostrar que
si tenemos dos triángulos diferentes que tienen un
par de lados con la misma longitud -estos lados
azules en cada uno de estos triángulos tienen
la misma longitud- y tienen dos pares de ángulos
donde cada par de ángulos correspondientes mide lo
mismo, este ángulo gris mide lo mismo que este
ángulo de aquí y luego estos arcos anaranjados
dobles muestran que este ángulo ACB tiene
la misma medida que el ángulo DFE, es decir,
que si tenemos dos de los ángulos y un lado con
la misma medida o longitud siempre podemos crear
una serie de transformaciones rígidas que mapeen
un triángulo sobre el otro. Otra forma de decirlo
es que, entonces, deben ser congruentes por la
definición de congruencia por transformaciones
rígidas. Y la razón por la que escribí ángulo,
lado, ángulo, o ASA por sus siglas en inglés aquí,
y ángulo, ángulo, lado, o AAS por sus siglas en
inglés, es para que vean que son equivalentes,
porque si tenemos dos ángulos entonces sabemos
cuál será el tercer ángulo. Por ejemplo,
en este caso si sabemos que tenemos dos pares de
ángulos que miden lo mismo, entonces significa
que el tercer par también debe medir lo mismo.
Entonces sabemos esto también. Si lo pensamos,
tener un lado entre los dos ángulos es equivalente
a tener un ángulo, un ángulo y un lado, porque
mientras tengamos dos ángulos el tercer ángulo
también tendrá la misma medida que el tercer
ángulo correspondiente del otro triángulo. Así
que vamos a mostrar una serie de transformaciones
rígidas que pueden llevarnos de ABC a DEF,
entonces pueden imaginarse el primer paso.
Ya hemos mostrado que, si tenemos dos segmentos
de igual longitud son congruentes, y podemos
hacer una serie de transformaciones rígidas que
mapeen uno sobre el otro. Entonces, lo que quiero
hacer es mapear el segmento AC en el DF, y la
forma en que podemos hacer esto es trasladar
el punto A para que esté sobre el punto D, así
que llamaré a esto A', y luego, cuando haga eso,
este segmento AC se verá más o menos así, sólo
lo estoy bocetando, tendrá esta dirección. Pero,
entonces, el resto del triángulo se moverá con
él, veamos: el resto de este lado anaranjado, el
lado AB, se verá algo así, y luego podemos hacer
otra transformación rígida que es rotar sobre el
punto D o el punto A', son el mismo punto ahora,
de modo que el punto C coincida con el punto F,
y así habremos hecho dos transformaciones
rígidas que mapean AC en DF. Y entonces A',
donde A está mapeado, ahora es igual a D y
F ahora es igual a C'. Pero la pregunta es:
¿dónde se encuentra ahora el punto B? Y aquí
tenemos que darnos cuenta de que se preservan
las medidas de cada ángulo y dado que las medidas
de los ángulos se conservan tenemos una situación
en la que este ángulo -el ángulo CAB- se conserva,
entonces sería C', A' y luego B' tendría que
ubicarse en algún lugar de este rayo, es decir: si
vamos a preservar la medida del ángulo CAB, B' se
encontrará en algún lugar a lo largo de este rayo,
D' se encontrará en algún lugar a lo largo de este
rayo porque un ángulo se define por dos rayos que
se cruzan en el vértice o comienzan en el vértice,
y debido a que este ángulo se conserva, el ángulo
que forman estos dos rayos, el rayo CA y el rayo
CB, sabemos que B' también tiene que ubicarse en
algún lugar de este rayo, así que B' tiene que
ubicarse en algún lugar de este rayo. Y creo que
se están dando cuenta de a dónde va esto: si B',
debido a que estos dos ángulos se conservan, este
ángulo y este ángulo se han conservado, tiene que
encontrarse en algún lugar de estos dos rayos que
se intersecan en un punto, justo este punto que
coincide con el punto E, entonces aquí es donde
estará B'. Este es un escenario en el cual hemos
mostrado que, con una serie de transformaciones
rígidas, podemos mapear este triángulo en este
otro triángulo. Sin embargo, hay otro escenario,
hay una circunstancia donde se conservan los
ángulos, pero en lugar de que los ángulos estén
en el lado inferior derecho de esta recta azul,
estos se conservan de tal manera que se encuentran
en el otro lado de esta recta azul, y entonces la
pregunta en esta situación es ¿dónde terminaría
B'? Bueno, permítanme dibujar esto un poco más
preciso, voy a replicar estos ángulos, voy a
dibujar un arco como este, un arco como este,
y luego mediré esta distancia. Ya hemos
hecho esto en otros videos cuando intentamos
replicar ángulos. Esta es la distancia y
déjenme dibujar esto con este punto aquí,
aquí. Si los ángulos están en este lado de la
recta, DF o A' C', sabemos que B' tendrá que
estar en algún lugar de este rayo. Voy a tratar
de dibujar esto tan prolijamente como pueda. En
algún lugar de este rayo, y tendría que estar
también en algún lugar del rayo formado por el
otro ángulo. Voy a ver si puedo dibujar esto lo
más prolijamente posible. Creo que hice esto un
poco más grande de lo necesario, pero espero que
sirva para nuestro propósito. Mido esta distancia
justo aquí y mido esta distancia por aquí, lo
que nos lleva hasta acá. Entonces B' se encuentra
en este rayo o podría ubicarse, aunque realmente
debo decir que tiene que ubicarse en este rayo.
Y podemos ver dónde se intersecan estos dos rayos,
justo allí. Entonces el otro escenario es que,
si los ángulos se conservan de manera que estén al
otro lado de esta recta azul, entonces B' estará
allí, y luego podríamos agregar una transformación
rígida más a nuestra serie de transformaciones
rígidas, que es esencialmente un reflejo desde la
recta DF o A' C'. ¿Por qué funcionaría eso para
asignar B' a E? Bueno, debido a que la reflexión
también es una transformación rígida se conservan
los ángulos, y a medida que este ángulo se refleja
se conserva, a medida que este ángulo se refleja
se conserva, y eso significa que llegaríamos al
primer caso en el que estos rayos se reflejarían
sobre estos rayos y B' tendría que ubicarse en
esta intersección. Y ahí lo tenemos: si conocemos
dos ángulos conocemos el tercero, si tenemos dos
ángulos y un lado que tienen la misma medida o
longitud, si hablamos de ángulo o lado, bueno, eso
significa que van a ser triángulos congruentes.